was ist angst klick zum science fiction
heute mit einem thema das passend zu
nein wo philip der mann im wissen dass
ich angst im dunkeln ab es dauert nicht
mehr lange dann steht halloween vor der
tür at die zeit in der hexen geister und
andere kreaturen aus dem tiefen der
kostüm kiste vor kriechen manche
verkleidungen sind dabei so gut dass sie
uns das fürchten lehren und wer angst
vor ihnen haben zusammen mit bosch in tv
habe ich einen kleinen versuch gemacht
wie leute zu erschrecken sind also die
versuchsanordnung ist folgendermaßen wie
will man leute richtig erschrecken das
geht natürlich nur mit diesen menschen
hier so schrecklich sie aber so sieht
wir sehen jetzt mal wie leute reagieren
und dann erkläre ich wieder so mit der
angst funktioniert oder was passiert
eigentlich wenn wir angst haben
die neben mehreren schritten schlagartig
ganz viel adrenalin aus dadurch schlägt
das herz schneller und das blut bindet
mehr sauerstoff
so wird der körper leistungsfähiger und
wir sind bereit schneller aus einer
situation zu fliehen oder uns besser zu
verteidigen dieser urinstinkt ist für
jeden organismus überlebenswichtig denn
stellt euch vor wir würden uns nicht vor
großen tieren oder naturkatastrophen
fürchten
der mensch würde nicht mehr existieren
angstreaktionen haben im allgemeinen
einen typischen zeitverlauf zunächst ist
die angst sehr hoch und somit auch
unsere alarmbereitschaft um schnell auf
situationen reagieren zu können
mit zunehmender zeit app die angst dann
langsam ab um nach folgenden situationen
immer noch mit erhöhter aufmerksamkeit
entgegen zu treten wie sich angst
aufbaut könnt ihr hier im ersten versuch
mit dem bildschirm sehen bis die
versuchsperson wirklich angst vor chris
ab dauert es ein paar sekunden bei der
alles wird generell zwischen zwei typen
unterschieden einerseits gibt es die
akute angst die wir in momenten haben
indem wir uns bedroht fühlen
stellt euch vor ihr seid ein tiger in
einem dunklen käfig hättet ihr da nicht
auch angst andererseits gibt es
permanente ängste die sich im laufe
unseres lebens entwickeln das sind dann
mehr oder weniger starke ängste sind
beispielsweise können bis zum dritten
lebensjahr die körper kommt
akt verlustangst die trennungsangst und
die sogenannte acht monats angst
auftreten
die wir meist als fremden bezeichnet sie
entwickeln sich aus der fähigkeit des
kindes nun zwischen anwesend und
abwesend fremd und vertraut
unterscheiden zu können in dieser zeit
entwickelt sich auch die angst vor der
dunkelheit
aber warum haben wir dafür überhaupt
angst weil wir uns nicht auf unseren
sehsinn verlassen können wie wir es
gewohnt sind mit den jahren gewöhnen wir
uns an die dunkelheit und das alles ist
nicht mehr so schlimm aber für ein
kleines kind ist es ziemlich ungewohnt
wenn plötzlich das licht aus ist und es
nichts mehr sieht in solchen situationen
kann auch eine panik entstehen
panik ist eine starke form der angst bei
der unser körper quasi überreagiert in
panikattacken verlieren wir teilweise
die kontrolle über uns selbst und unser
körper ist nur darauf bedacht die
situation zu überleben auch wenn die
situation möglicherweise gar nicht so
bedrohlich ist wie wir sie zunächst
einschätzen
im versuch mit den jungs von busch n tv
hat das mit der panik scheinbar ganz gut
geklappt
auch im zusammenhang mit angst stehen
phobien sie bezeichnen an störungen
kommt aus dem griechischen und bedeutet
soviel wie furcht oder schrecken eine
phobie wird auch als real angst
bezeichnet da sie in den momenten
auftritt in denen wir uns bedroht fühlen
ängste treten auch unterschiedlich stark
auf für den einen ist eine
achterbahnfahrt das totale vergnügen
andere wiederum trauen sich erst gar
nicht mit zu fahren
wie stark eine angst ausgeprägtes hängt
von einigen faktoren ab dazu zählt unter
anderem das persönliche umfeld
aber wie überwindet man eine angst die
wohl bekannteste methode ist die
konfrontationstherapie der proband wird
also mit seiner angst konfrontiert
beispielsweise mit einer spinne
zusammengebracht
dadurch soll die angst abtrainiert
werden aber auch wenn wir die empfundene
angst abschwächen können bleibt eine
gewisse ängstlichkeit nach wie vor
bestehen mehr zombie invasion - gibt es
bei joker von den spaceballs an michael
jacksons villa prank sensationell um bei
djokovic könnt ihr die unterschiede
zwischen männern und frauen sehen wenn
sie horror filme schauen die links dafür
natürlich auch in der video beschreibung
ansonsten bis dann
blatter